turning now to the war in Ukraine Russia
launched a new wave of drone attacks
overnight after strikes on cities killed
three civilians on New Year's Eve these
attacks come as bitter fighting
continues in some parts of the country
after recent Ukrainian successes on the
battlefield Ian Lee visited one
Ukrainian Health City that's turned into
a test of Wills between the two armies
we are on the road to the most dangerous
place in Ukraine soldiers call it a meat
grinder locals call it hell on Earth
welcome to Bach mood one thing that
we're seeing driving into bakmut is
artillery and hangs a lot of heavy
equipment along the roads
most buildings here show scars from
months of fighting
Russia continuously throws wave after
wave of troops at the city amid the
sounds of battle
we see people huddled next to a grocery
store
we have to stay in lines like this for
food she tells me just two days ago a
strike scattered everyone but we came
back and that's how we live and for what
so many people have died would you leave
if you were able to
no she says this is our home
but Natalia wanted to flee with her
family
she tells us she tried before but her
son was killed he was only two weeks
from his 17th birthday Natalia now keeps
her daughter close by her side and
what's your name
are you scared
you're a brave girl how old are you
you're four years old what do you hope
for your daughter for the future
I want only the best Natalia tells me I
don't want her to see all of this I
don't want her to suffer and meet the
same fate as her older brother
moot the air constant constantly rattles
with death but life goes on people run
errands even the trash still needs
collecting
why we've been in Bak mood we've heard
constant artillery strikes going out and
coming in leaving damage like this but
it's just a small part of what's going
on across Ukraine Russia continues to
fire drones and missiles into the
country killing civilians and destroying
critical infrastructure
the war has been an education for people
here clearly not one they wanted
was that close
it landed somewhere far off she tells me
it was outgoing not incoming close is
when the windows are shattered and the
houses that's close she says
[Music]
every day more windows shatter more
houses are destroyed but as the rally
cry goes bachmud still holds
you could feel people's anxiety when
talking to them there was a lot of fear
but also of sort of resignation that
their fate whether they live or die is
not in their hands Adriana
can't help but think of how this war
will shape the children that you
interview in their future thank you so
much for your reporting